trolls
big dumb and ugly
creatures that have become another
staple of modern fantasy
but what if the trolls we know today
differed in the past
what if there was more to them today we
are indeed diving back into norse
mythology and scandinavian folklore
as we take a look at the history of
trolls and how they appear today
honey what are you doing this video is
about trolls not goblins
you had your chance in the goblin video
and you blew it now get back in your
cage
you filthy little goblin honey
no i'm not giving you any more money
last time i lent you money you went
straight to the casino no stupid
honey oh honey
goblins and trolls may be extremely
annoying
and very very stupid creatures
but even they know when a great offer is
smacking them in the face
and speaking of being smacked in the
face by a great offer today's video is
sponsored by honey
the free browser extension that helps
you find promo codes and saves you money
when shopping online
if 2021 is anything like this year then
i know i need a new coffee machine
or maybe your pet dog goblin has chewed
up the baby yoda cushions you bought as
presents and now you need to replace
them
once i proceed to the checkout before i
pay for my order honey will scour the
web for any available promo codes and
apply them for me
as you can see here it's found a 10
discount code and i've saved
pound 20 for doing nothing adding the
honey extension
is completely free it works on all
browsers and only takes a few clicks to
install
all you have to do is visit
joinhoney.com
myth and fiction that's joinhoney.com
myth and fiction a big thanks to honey
for sponsoring this video
if you'd also like to see if you can
save some money during the holiday
period then check them out today
when discussing trolls elves or any
supernatural creature that appears or is
mentioned in norse mythology it's
important to note that they may
differ from today's expectations in
modern fantasy most of these terms refer
to a specific race
and it's fairly easy to identify said
race with a brief description
of their appearance or behavior early
20th century authors such as robert e
howard tolkien and many others certainly
contributed to this
in the north sagas it's pretty much the
reverse in old icelandic
the term troll or trollslager refers to
numerous supernatural beings such as
ghosts and witches it's not a term that
can be
easily defined nor was it meant to be
if it was meant to refer to something
scary then having a level of ambiguity
certainly leaves room for the
imagination
the easiest comparison i can make today
is with the
bogey or boogeyman it has no set
appearance but we know it's supposed to
mean something scary
we do know however the negative
connotation of a troll
extends to more than just being
something scary
waking a troll from their slumber was
forbidden just as it was to sit down and
have a meal with one
this one led to the idea that trolls may
have been witches and heretics who had
been
excommunicated therefore we can look at
a troll as someone living in isolation
someone whose society deemed a nuisance
with no real value
the first attempts to define trolls in
norse myth then came
much later where the term was used to
describe a number of things from
yotna and witches to someone who may
have just been
abnormally big or very ugly most of the
time
they could be found dwelling inside of
rocks mountains and caves by themselves
interactions with them are almost always
negative
and as we mentioned earlier they were
considered someone
or something you should probably avoid
hundreds of years later in scandinavian
folklore trolls became
much more defined they were very old and
extremely large creatures
with their strength being their biggest
asset picking a fight with a troll
head-on would be ill-advised
as their favorite meal was man flesh as
seen in many of the early stories
the way to best a troll is to outsmart
them as they are rather slow and
dim-witted
a story that i remember being told as a
child is the norwegian fairy tale three
billy goats gruff
the story itself was first published in
1841
but is still told even to this day the
story is about three billy goats
trying to cross a bridge in the story i
was told
the goats are brothers but their
relation can vary
the meadow where the goats live has no
more grass to eat
so they have to cross the river into the
next meadow where the grass is indeed
greener
in order to do so they have to cross a
bridge
under this bridge lives an evil troll
when the youngest brother crosses he is
stopped by the troll
you would make for a lovely meal the
youngest goat does not panic
instead he outsmarts the troll why would
you want to eat me
i'm just a baby my brother behind me is
much bigger
you should eat him and so the troll
agrees
allowing the smallest goat to pass
safely when the next brother crosses the
troll stops him and gives him the same
threat yes bigger indeed
you will also make for a lovely meal
the middle brother copies the youngest
you could eat me right now
but you'd still be hungry why not wait
for our oldest brother
he'll feed you for days once again the
troll agrees to let the goat
pass safely when the eldest brother
crosses he is given the same threat
oh yes you will feed me for days
this time he does not try to outsmart
the troll
the eldest brother is much bigger he
charges towards the troll
and knocks him off the bridge with his
horns the troll is then carried away by
the current and never seen again
the three billy goats and anyone who
uses the bridge
live happily ever after i know when we
discuss goblins there were tales of them
kidnapping children and this also
applies for trolls
the swedish author helena neiblum wrote
a fairy tale
titled the changeling in this story a
princess
is snatched from her cradle by a troll
who leaves his
own child in her place both of these
children grow up
never really being accepted because of
how different they are
a troll being raised by humans and a
human being raised by trolls
may create an issue or two the human
princess
is repulsed by the troll way of living
and the troll princess
is bored by the human way once they come
of age and must find a husband
they decide it's time to escape and
return home
both of them pass each other in the
forest not knowing who the other one is
reuniting with their rightful families
they live happily ever
after finding the acceptance they
desired
the illustration for this story shows us
that trolls may not have always been
seen
as large creatures nibbling story aside
swedish trolls do tend to be
on the larger side big enough you often
see them depicted in the shape of a
mountain
or an entire forest trolls in swedish
folklore maintain a connection to nature
there is also the belief that lightning
and thunder would scare trolls away
this goes back to the term troll once
being used to describe
a yoten thor being the god of lightning
and thunderstorms coupled with his
disdain for the yotna
means that thunder and lightning to a
troll may signify that thor is nearby
and they might be about to get their
head smashed in
trolls were also not too fond of church
bells
in some stories when towns and villages
were plagued by trolls
they would routinely ring their bells to
force the trolls to leave
a common response to this was for the
trolls to attack and destroy
churches normally hurling large rocks
and boulders from a distance as to not
get too close to the bells when you come
across scandinavian landmarks that
involve
large rock formations they will
sometimes be described
as the remains of boulders thrown by
trolls or even as trolls who have been
turned into stone from gazing into the
sun
in norway and denmark you have what they
refer to as
troll folk and mountain folk these
trolls are much smaller but they can
still grow to the size of a man
they're said to be found living in
burial grounds caves and
other dark places which implies they may
also dislike sunlight
so i guess with all of this information
we can try to understand
how trolls have changed over the years
we know there are different types of
trolls
mountain trolls you could argue would be
amongst the biggest
forest trolls would be able to blend in
with their environment the best
river trolls live under bridges and
internet trolls are by far the most
grotesque and unloved hence their
constant need for attention
there are some other shared
characteristics such as being
dimwitted unable to stay in direct
sunlight
and having a taste for human flesh
what i find interesting is the change in
attitudes towards trolls
the earliest trolls were ambiguous
figures that were meant to scare you
in order to keep you away but as time
went on
they became much more comical we see
this in the earlier scandinavian fairy
tales
trolls appear quite often as the butt of
a joke
or as a character that exists to be
bested by the protagonist
in modern fiction and cinema you do get
quite an even split between
comical trolls and terrifying trolls i
know for me growing up i can think of
two very different film experiences
you have the troll in the girls bathroom
in the first harry potter which even as
a child
you could tell was meant to be somewhat
comical and then you have the troll in
the minds of moria in the fellowship of
the ring which is
not so comical regardless of how we see
trolls today there is no denying they
have a rich
and interesting history as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
right i can finally go to the bathroom
shopping time what are you doing now i i
didn't even leave the room
nothing you were about to try and buy a
hundred baby yodas again weren't you
no you know what i'm done i'm done
i know a guy in finland who wants to
trade a baby troll for a goblin
and that seems like a pretty good deal
to me but it's christmas
yeah it is christmas and you'll get to
spend it in lapland with santa and his
elves
now get away from the laptop and go and
pack your bags you grubby little goblin
handbag i hate humans
[Music]
you